In a move that could throw the release of
Fast and Furious 9 into a tailspin, AMC Theatres
says its plans to release any Universal-backed
films are coming to a screeching halt after
the studio announced its record-breaking success
with Trolls World Tour.
The head of the American movie theater chain
sent NBCUniversal a blistering message after
comments from its CEO Jeff Shell implied the
Hollywood studio might be moving forward with
a dual theatrical and at-home release model.
Adam Aron, AMC Theatres' chair-CEO, said in
a letter to the studio:
"It is disappointing to us, but Jeff's comments
as to Universal's unilateral actions and intentions
have left us with no choice.
Therefore, effectively immediately AMC will
no longer play any Universal movies in any
of our theaters in the United States, Europe
or the Middle East."
Nearly all of AMC's 11,000 screens across
the globe have gone black, as the world's
largest theater circuit was forced to close
locations indefinitely following government-imposed
limits on social gatherings amid the coronavirus
pandemic.
While some states are lifting their restrictions
in the coming weeks, the nation-wide closures
in March caused studios to push their spring
release slate to late summer at the earliest,
leaving theater owners with nothing to screen
and little reason to reopen.
But Aron's statement assures that even when
they do, the decades-long business relationship
between AMC Theatres and NBCUniversal will
have, quote, "sadly come to an end."
"You don't turn your back on family."
Originally geared up for a May 9 theatrical
debut, Universal tentpole F9 is among the
growing list of titles delayed due to the
ongoing pandemic.
Universal pushed the ninth chapter of its
high-octane Fast and Furious franchise by
a whole year to April 2, 2021.
The shift followed earlier comments from star
Vin Diesel promising fans that the May 2020
release of F9, which will see the return of
fan-favorite character Han, was still on.
Unlike its plan with F9, Universal made the
huge decision amid the coronavirus pandemic
to ditch a theatrical release window for Trolls
World Tour in favor of a premium video on
demand debut.
It was unclear how successful the gamble would
be, but the animated sequel reportedly exceeded
NBCUniversal's expectations, earning an estimated
$100 million in the first three weeks of its
North American VOD launch.
Shell told The Wall Street Journal:
"As soon as theaters reopen, we expect to
release movies on both formats."
Neither AMC nor NATO, the National Association
of Theatre Owners, responded well to Shell's
comment.
After declaring that the policy announcement
was, quote, "not some hollow or ill-considered
threat," Aron added that it would apply to
anyone considering expanding into a premium
video on demand model.
"Not this time, Dom."
A speedy and pointed response from Universal
clarified that Shell's comments on release
window and platform plans had been misunderstood.
According to the studio statement, theatrical
releases were never off the table, with NBCUniversal
only planning to do, quote, "PVOD when that
distribution outlet makes sense."
The statement reads in part:
"We look forward to having additional private
conversations with our exhibition partners,
but are disappointed by this seemingly coordinated
attempt from AMC and NATO to confuse our position
and our actions."
If an agreement between AMC and Universal
can't be met between now and when theaters
do reopen, fans may never get to see F9 race
into theaters.
In its own follow-up statement, the National
Association of Theater Owners challenged Universal's
characterization of theater owners' response
as, quote, "a coordinated attempt" at misrepresenting
Shell's quote.
Patrick Corcoran, the group's vice president
and CCO, said:
"Unfortunately, Universal has a destructive
tendency to both announce decisions affecting
their exhibitor partners without actually
consulting with those partners, and now of
making unfounded accusations."
The entire debacle, which took place mostly
over a day, highlighted an increasingly tense
relationship between theater owners and movie
studios.
Nearly a decade after rental and streaming
services practically ended the DVD market,
theater owners are facing declining ticket
sales and an expensive ongoing effort to modernize
various elements of the theater-going experience.
Following the closures in March, some Wall
Street analysts have even predicted AMC might
be forced to file for Chapter 11 bankruptcy.
Despite its woes, a world where the fantastical
action and drama of Dom Toretto's crew never
grace the big screen seems incomprehensible.
For some, so too is the idea that Universal's
success with Trolls World Tour's PVOD release
is sustainable.
The movie's $100 million earnings are notable
because NBCUniversal was able to achieve that
by charging at-home viewers $19.99 not to
buy the film, but merely to rent it for two
days.
But as NATO president and CEO John Fithian
said in the organization's response to the
studio, it achieved this during, quote, "unusual
circumstances in an unprecedented environment."
He explained:
"Theaters provide a beloved immersive, shared
experience that cannot be replicated an experience
that many of the VOD viewers of this film
would have participated in had the world not
been sequestered at home, desperate for something
new to watch with their families."
It's unclear how this will all turn out, but
for the sake of Fast and Furious fans, let's
hope it all blows over in time for the 2021
premiere.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.